-Performing "Worth It,"
featuring Don Toliver,
from his new album "Set It Off,"
give it up for Offset.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wake the town, tell the people.
-CHASETHEMONEY, CHASETHEMONEY.
♪♪
-♪ You got me, got me workin' ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ I hope it's worth it ♪
♪ You tell me you're with him
on purpose ♪
♪ You're doin' whatever
to hurt me ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ And ain't nobody can do it
like you, yeah, nah, nah ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ I need everything cool
in the coupe like yah-yah ♪
♪ Merry-go-round like a circus ♪
♪ I wanna buy a new Birkin ♪
-♪ Birkin ♪
-♪ She wanna pop a new Perky ♪
-♪ Eliantte on my body,
diamonds hittin' ♪
♪ It's hard to catch a vibe ♪
♪ Or go outside
without you trippin' ♪
♪ Got...tryna line me, I can't
ride without my blicky ♪
♪ I bought my bitch a Kelly
crocodile but not no... ♪
-♪ Hey, hey, hey ♪
-♪ Bringin' up the past,
the...I done done before ♪
♪ Your feet all in the sand,
I flew her to Cabo ♪
♪ Her friend got a lil' Benz,
she wanted the Range Rove ♪
♪ I'm watchin' on your 'Gram,
you givin' them angles ♪
♪ I'm payin' for it ♪
♪ You ain't never gotta stress
about no landlord ♪
♪ You ain't never gotta ask me,
"What you plan for?" ♪
♪ Private jet, we puttin' stamps
all on your passport ♪
♪ I got plans for it,
leave your man for it ♪
-♪ You got me, got me workin' ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ I hope it's worth it ♪
♪ You told me you're with him
on purpose ♪
♪ You're doin' whatever
to hurt me ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ And ain't nobody can do it
like you, yeah, nah, nah ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ I need everything cool
in the coupe like yah-yah ♪
-♪ Merry-go-round
like a circus ♪
♪ I wanna buy a new Birkin ♪
♪ She wanna pop a new Perky ♪
-♪ You know you want me,
so what you be playin' for? ♪
♪ The message say delivered,
so what you delayin' for? ♪
♪ You think I'm out...around,
I'm in the studio ♪
♪ It's petty...tellin'
your friends all the... ♪
♪ Now your heart cold...around,
buy you a mink coat ♪
♪ All your friends got on
Chanel, only hoes, squad goals ♪
♪ I'll go narco,
whack any...that seem... ♪
♪ It's a double-R hearse,
lil' mama, you seein' ghosts ♪
♪ I know you're tight with me,
you know the type of...I am ♪
♪ I shoot it spitefully, I don't
give a damn what they sayin' ♪
♪ You better fight for me ♪
♪ Want me or you don't, tell the
truth, don't be lyin' to me ♪
♪ Want you to be my peace,
'cause these streets get grimy ♪
♪ See you with another...
I'll be damned ♪
♪ Better not catch him
out in traffic ♪
♪ 'Cause my gun don't jam ♪
♪ You better pick up
when you can ♪
[ Line ringing ]
Whoo.
-Your call has been forwarded
to an automatic
voice message system.
Zero.
-Hey, hey.
-♪ You got me, got me workin' ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ I hope it's worth it ♪
♪ You tell me you're with him
on purpose ♪
♪ You're doin' whatever
to hurt me ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ And ain't nobody can do it
like you, yeah, nah, nah ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ I need everything cool
in the coupe like yah-yah ♪
♪ Merry-go-round like a circus ♪
-♪ I wanna buy a new Birkin ♪
-♪ Birkin ♪
-♪ She wanna pop a new Perky ♪
-♪ Perky ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whoo!